so you led the openai robotics team can
you give an overview of of the cool
things you're able to accomplish what
are you most proud of
so when we started robotics we knew that
actually reinforcement learning works
and it is possible to solve very
complicated problems
like for instance alphago is an evidence
that it is possible to to build
superhuman and goal players dota 2 is a
an evidence that is possible to build
superhuman
agents playing dota so i asked myself a
question you know what about robots out
there could we train machines to solve
arbitrary tasks in the physical world
our approach was i guess let's pick a
complicated problem that
if we would solve it that means that we
made some uh significant progress in the
domain and then we went after the
problem
so um
we noticed that actually the robots out
there they are kind of at the moment
optimized per task so you can have a
robot that it's like if you have a robot
opening a battle it's very likely that
the end factor is a battle opener
and uh and in some sense that's a hack
to be able to solve a task which makes
any task easier and um ask myself so
what would be a robot that can actually
solve many tasks yeah and we conclude
that that
like a human hands have such a quality
that indeed they are you know you have
five kind of tiny arms attached
individually they can manipulate
pretty broad spectrum of objects so we
went after a single hand like a trying
to solve rubik's cube single-handed we
picked this task because we thought that
there is no way to
hard-code it and it's also we picked the
robot on which it would be hard to
hard-code and we went after the solution
such that
it could generalize to other problems
and just to clarify it's
one robotic hand solving the rubik's
cube the hard part isn't the solution to
the rubik's cube is the manipulation of
the uh of like having it not fall out of
the hand having it
use the uh
five baby arms
to uh what is it like rotate different
parts of the rubik's cube to achieve the
solution correct yeah so what uh what
was the hardest part about that
what was the approach taken there what
are you most proud of obviously we have
like a strong belief in reinforcement
learning
and
you know one path it is to do
reinforcement learning the real world
other path is to uh the simulation in
some sense the
tricky part about the real world is at
the moment our models they require a lot
of data there is essentially no data
and
i did we decided to go through the path
of the simulation and in simulation you
can have infinite amount of data the
tricky part is the fidelity of the
simulation and also can you in
simulation represent everything that you
represent otherwise in the real world
and you know it turned out that
that you know because there is lack of
fidelity it is possible to that what we
what we
arrived at is training a model that
doesn't solve one simulation but it
actually solves the
entire range of simulations which uh
vary uh in terms of like uh what's the
exactly the friction of that cube or the
weight or so
and the
single ai that can solve all of them
ends up working well with the reality
how do you generate the different
simulations so
you know there's plenty of parameters
out there we just pick them randomly and
and in simulation model just goes for
thousands of years and keeps on solving
rubik's cube in each of them and the
thing is the neural network that we used
it has a
memory
and as it presses for instance the side
of the
of the cube it can sense oh that's
actually this side was
uh difficult to press i should press it
stronger and throughout this process
kind of
learns even how to
how to solve this particular instance of
the rubik's cube back event mass it's
kind of like a
you know sometimes when you
go to a gym and after
after bench press you
try to lift the glass
and you kind of forgot uh and and your
hand goes like yeah right away because
kind of you got this to maybe different
weight yeah and it takes a second to
adjust yeah
and this kind of of a memory that model
gained through the process of
interacting with the cube in the
simulation
i appreciate you speaking to the
audience with the bench press all the
bros in the audience
probably working out right now there's
probably somebody listening to this
actually doing bench press
um so maybe
uh put the bar down and pick up the
water bottle and you'll know exactly
what uh what check is talking about okay
so what uh
what was the hardest part of getting the
whole thing to work so the hardest part
is
at the moment when it comes to a
physical world
when it comes to robots
they require maintenance it's hard to
replicate a million times
it's uh it's also it's hard to replay
things exactly
i remember this situation that
one guy
at our company he had like a model that
performs way better than other models in
solving rubik's cube and
you know we kind of didn't know what's
going on
why it's that
and
it turned out
that you know he was running it from his
laptop that had better cpu or
or better or maybe local gpu as well and
because of that there was less of a
latency and the model was the same
and that actually
made solving rubik's cube more reliable
so in some sense there might be some
saddlebacks like that when it comes to
running things in the real world
even hinting on that
you could imagine that the initial
models you would like to have models
which are insanely huge neural networks
and you would like to give them even
more time for thinking
and when you have these real-time
systems
then
you might be constrained actually by the
amount of latency
and uh ultimately i would like to build
the system that it is
worth for you to wait five minutes
because it gives you the answer
that you are willing to wait for five
minutes so latency is a very unpleasant
constraint under which to operate
correct and also there is actually one
more thing which is tricky about robots
there is actually
no not much data so the data that i'm
speaking about would be a data of
first person experience from the robot
and like a gigabytes of data like that
if we would have gigabytes of data like
that of robot solving party's problems
it would be very easy to make a progress
on robotics and you can see that in case
of text or code there is a lot of data
like a first person perspective data on
the writing code
yeah so you had this
you mentioned this really interesting
idea that
if you were to build like a successful
robotics company so open as mission is
much bigger than robotics this is one of
the
one of the things you worked on
but if it was a robotics company
they you wouldn't so quickly dismiss
supervised learning i correct that you
would build a robot
that
uh was perhaps one like
um an empty shell like dumb and they
would operate under tele operation
so you would invest
that's just one way to do it
invest in human super like direct human
control of the robots as it's learning
and over time add more and more
automation
that's correct so let's say that's how i
would build a robotics company today
if i would be building a robotics
company which is you know spent 10
million dollars or so
recording human trajectories controlling
a robot after you find
a thing that the robot should be doing
that there's a market fit for like you
can make a lot of money with that
product correct correct yeah
so
i would record data and then i would
essentially train supervised learning
model on it
that might be the path today
long term i think that actually what is
needed is to
train powerful models over video
so
you have seen maybe a models that can
generate images like dali
and people are looking into models
generating videos they're like parties
algorithmic questions even how to do it
and it's unclear if there is enough
compute for this purpose but
i i suspect that the models that which
would have a
level of understanding of video
same as gpt has a level of understanding
of text
could be used
uh
to train robots to solve tasks they
would have a lot of common sense
you